So let's see if we understood
the coherence definition.
Let's say that we have two cores, in a
system that is supposed to be coherent.
Let's say that core 1
executes this program.
It sets A = 1, then waits for
A to change from 1, so it's going to
loop here as long as A == 1.
Sets A again to 1, and
then prints done one.
At the same time when core one is
started on this, core two starts on
another program that writes zero to
the same location A in shared memory,
waits until a changes from zero, sets
A to zero again, then prints done two.
And remember that core one and
core two, need not necessarily execute
these two programs in lockstep.
So it's not necessary that core one
executes this while core two does this,
core one does this while
core two this and so on.
It could be for example that core one
executes several of these while core
two is still not even beginning.
So you can insert
arbitrary delays in between
any of the statements here and here.
The question for you is which of
the following print outs are possible?
First, core one prints Done 1!,
then core two prints Done 2!.
The next possibility,
first core two prints Done 2!,
then core one prints Done 1!
The next option,
core one prints Done 1!,
but core two gets stuck and
never gets to print Done 2!.
The next option is
core one gets stuck and
never gets to print Done 1!, but
core two successfully prints Done 2!.
And the final option, is that
nothing is printed because both of
the cores gets stuck, so
neither of them prints anything ever.
So which of these five
options are actually possible
when these two programs
run in a coherent system?